qu'on pense à monsieur péladeau beaucoup
étudiants pourquoi maintenant pourquoi
maintenant c'est le bon moment pour vous
d'annoncer la relance de cette
entreprise avec un modèle d'offre
d'affaires quand même qui transforme et
oui
bastien à celui quand même parce qu'elle
est peut-être à l'exceptionnelle adrian
bien expliquer la nouvelle dynamique
indéniablement donc il ya des
changements majeurs qui se sont produits
entre aujourd'hui et donc à l'origine de
théo et à cet égard elle a complètement
raison maintenant pourquoi aujourd'hui
lorsque j'ai fait l'acquisition donc de
taxer locaux comme on dit à la barre du
tribunal vous souviendrez des
difficultés financières d'ailleurs vous
avez fait référence c'était pour la
relance de théo ans il fallait quand
même prendre le temps de mettre en place
justement je vois que montrer
l'application bien s'assurer que nous
allions avoir alors à ce moment-là les
outils nécessaires technologique pour
s'assurer qu'on allait faire un bon
travail on se d'obtenir les véhicules et
là aussi une bonne description c'était
important donc de s'assurer que nous
allions avoir des véhicules avec une
note une autonomie allongée ce qu'il
commette mans avec la soul qui a acquis
une autonomie de plus de 300 km est
également aussi de revoir le wild à
faire le mentionner ce ne sont plus les
salari ce sont des entrepreneurs
indépendants dont il s'agit est
changeante nous sommes monsieur péladeau
ça change tout d'avoir une technologie
qui est meilleur mais aussi d'avoir des
travailleurs autonomes et non pas des
travailleurs salariés syndiqués la
volonté de monsieur taillefer c'était
aussi d'avoir un bassin de travailleurs
bien protégé avec des avantages mais on
n'est plus du tout la dinde
oui mais en même temps aussi bien le
bien mentionné c'est donc la loi la
déréglementation donc de l'environnement
dans lequel alexandre avait démarré son
activité il souhaitait qui est d'aider
amenuisement ou des aménagements pour
faire en sorte de pouvoir être en mesure
de
d'offrir une prestation équivalente
notamment en fonction de la taille et de
la tarification dynamique donc
aménagements qui était déjà en faire par
hubert une entreprise comme on dit c'est
international une multinationale qui
paie pas ses impôts ici au québec n'ont
donc ça va faire la différence entre
théorie ibr la belle théorique mais y'en
a pas sinon qu effectivement teos est
également donc de transport électrique
c'est du transport clients dont
l'énergie est une énergie locale une
énergie qui donc économise donc dans les
gaz à effet de serre vous avez un
véhicule électrique c'est 15 tonnes de
co2 de moins ça c'est extrêmement
important et on va continuer évidemment
à s'assurer avec le service à la
clientèle
dray à la hauteur des expectatives des
clients sachant que la marque est où là
aussi vous l'avez mentionné la marque
théo était une marque extrêmement
respectée dans la part des montréalaises
et combien ces deux-là dru on a racheté
donc que l'entreprise où je viendrai
peut-être c'est un monta public cinq
millions de dollars est dorénavant donc
au fur et à mesure du déploiement des
véhicules vous savez donc le modèle
d'affaires comme je le mentionnais un
peu plus tôt et changer de celui de théo
à l'origine et avec taxer le combat nous
sommes également aussi et surtout donc
nous nous procurons des courses à ceux
et celles qui vont conduire des
véhicules
nous allons procurer des facilités de
financement pour qu' on puisse faire
l'acquisition d'un véhicule électrique
mais ce sont les propriétaires donc les
entrepreneurs qui seront propriétaires
hockey de la vie qu'ils allaient faire
appel au fonds vert lors vous savez
qu'il ya une initiative évidemment qui
et c'est une très bonne chose et où
souviendrez que le fonds vert avait
beaucoup d'argent à dépenser chez
bombardier chez air canada pour des
élèves
rien de spécifiquement adressé pour la
réduction des gaz à effet de serre on ne
peut faire l'économie de cette équipe de
la réduction des gaz à effet serre sinon
par le transport et particulièrement le
transport des passagers et
éventuellement également un transport
des marchandises et en s'engager dans
cette direction là c'est s'engager
véritablement vers la diminution des gaz
à effet de serre oui et c'est la raison
qu'elles je pense que le fonds vert
avant une véritable mission alors
qu'antérieurement on ne savait pas
véritablement à ce qu'ils avaient
l'intention de temps dont vous allez
faire appel au fonds vert comme toutes
les entreprises qui ne sont pas engagés
dans la réduction des gaz à effet de
serre mais je pense que c'est une très
belle initiative que leur maman du
québec pour vos pensées et osons espérer
également aussi que le gouvernement du
canada va s'engager dans cette direction
là parce que des impôts des québécois
qui sont envoyés à ottawa devrait
justement faire en sorte qu'on puisse
bénéficier d'un retour d'ascenseur et on
sait très bien qu'au québec
mais c'est là où le transport électrique
est le plus développé je rêve dans le
transport mais je venais un petit peu
plus haut est ce que vous êtes
intéressés à soumettre une nouvelle
offre pour transat 80000 pire à peu près
aussi que vous avez suivi évidemment
avec intérêt et avec attention
vous savez donc que si loin d'être une
transaction tamini parce que ça retient
donc des autorisations administratives
vous savez que le bureau de la
concurrence a émis des recommandations
qui était pas particulièrement favorable
parce que on sait fort bien que la
conséquence du rachat de transat par air
canada
ça va être la constitution d'un
quasi-monopole plus de 60% donc des
lignes aériennes sur la desserte
européennes vont dorénavant être
soucieuse une seule entreprise donc le
bureau de la concurrence se fait ce
commentaire imaginer parce que là aussi
on a besoin de l'autorisation au niveau
de la commission européenne comment la
commission européenne ne retiendrait pas
d avis du bureau de la concurrence
canadien ce qui me fait ramener puis il
n'y a pas de juste mot penser que cette
transaction véritablement du plomb dans
l aile
oui puisque et d'octroi des
autorisations ça sera pas une mince
tâche
et donc est ce que vous êtes intéressé à
faire une nouvelle offre jeu
j'analyse dossiers comme ceux de
l'analyse ait précédemment et évidemment
voici des considérations sur lesquels
évidemment on va devoir réactualisé ma
perspective et j'ai compris que les
pouvoirs publics avaient indiqué que
pour l'un
t'at il n'y avait pas d'avs il y en a
une nouvelle on nous allons regarder
parce que toute la documentation n'est
pas nécessairement encore produite nous
avons entendu que l'assemblée des
actionnaires pour réguler le 8 décembre
donc je peux vous assurer c'est un
dossier sur lequel je déploie beaucoup
d'intérêt mais ça coûterait moins cher
le monsieur péladeau quand même ça
baisser de rideau
oui mais le bilan également aussi est
certainement moins fort qu'il était
précédemment t la transaction
souvenez-vous le quand même y avait
suffisamment de excusez moi l'expression
de cash en encaisse dans le bilan qui
faisait en sorte qu'on payait une grande
partie de l'acquisition par le biais de
l'anc est même de l'entreprise dont on
faisait l'acquisition notamment donc en
l'occurrence transat dont les liquidités
ont diminué pour regarder le bilan avec
davantage de détails
vous savez que les résultats ont été
divulgués au début du mois de septembre
ça va être pour nous l'occasion d'y
regarder à plus amplement et plus
profondément
merci beaucoup monsieur péladeau vous en
prie de se finir merci beaucoup